hey everyone welcome back to game Sports
coverage of e3 2019 I'm Lucy James
joined as ever by Mike Mahadi I'm
Leonard Boyarsky the code-named director
on the outer world Leonard welcome thank
you so last year you announced the game
and at the Game Awards and there was a
incredible reaction people dying to see
more of this kind of title like the
Elseworlds you know this irreverent
humor this immersion this RPG system now
at e3 what are you showing we put a
glimpse of it a couple days ago
Microsoft but and we have a release date
but what else are you showing here I'm
having a close behind closed door kind
of thing where we're showing off a
portion of the game that takes place on
monarch which is one of the inhabited
planets in the system it's been
abandoned by the board the corporate
board kind of runs the whole system and
you know organized crime and and
renegade corporations have kind of kind
of run the place
but it's blockaded so it's kind of a
lawless frontier of the of the game
obsidian has this rich history of RPGs
right
I wonder just going like sci-fi does
that create like too many possibilities
do you feel like almost there there's
not enough limit on what you could do in
the outer worlds no not for me I'm
really fired up to be doing a science
fiction game after all this time the
first game that Tim and I created
together with with the group of people
obviously was fallout and that's kind of
sort of science fiction but it's a very
specific genre of post-apocalyptic and
then we did Arcanum together which is
you know industrial fantasy so this is
our first foray into pure science
fiction and I don't know why it took
this long this is one of my favorite
genres to do so I'm really excited to be
doing something that's pure sci-fi what
do you what have you been looking at for
inspiration all kinds of things it
depends you know what aspect of it we're
talking about I like looking at you know
authors like Vonnegut some early
Vonnegut stuff I talked to my writers
all the time about some Coen Brothers
also we looked at things like True Grit
and Deadwood obviously Firefly because
we really wanted that kind of western
frontier and space kind of thing going
on and then of course there's a lot of
things that I've wanted to do ever since
I did Fallout was the art director on
the original Fallout that
never got a chance to explore so that's
why you're gonna see a lot of very heavy
chunky industrialization which is you
know something I really like to explore
artistically I think because of your
history with fallout with and like
especially New Vegas it's easy I think a
lot of people are saying oh this is like
that fallout formula or like New Vegas
in space is there any accuracy to that
or is there more than meets the eye to
how this game is going to flow from one
event I think yes or no because I think
that it's not so much of us like saying
we're gonna do another version of that
as that's kind of grew out of something
that we kind of created a long time ago
so it's only natural for us to return to
that kind of thing and the reason I
think it feels so much like it is
because it's very much a reflection of
mine and timpz personalities I have a
very dark sense of humor he gets kind of
silly so we put those two things
together and that's kind of you know
that's the tone of the Fallout series
and it's so it's obviously carried over
here because that's just how we are we
were given free reign when we first made
fallout I mean that's kind of what we
came up with just out of you know our
own heads no one telling us what we
could or couldn't do so it's kind of the
same thing here we started from scratch
there was nothing laid out for us it was
we had a wide-open canvas or a blank
canvas to work with so of course it's
gonna feel a lot like that I think it
you know it's going to share a lot with
any first-person RPG I think the things
besides even the tone is that you know
we've ever since the original Fallout
and Arcanum we we always loved games
where you have a blank slate as the
player character you can make any type
of hero or villain that you want to be
in the game react to that it's very much
driven by your choices as a player so
since that was embraced by New Vegas
it's only natural that people are gonna
see that similarity you mentioned that
you kind of had free rein to develop
anything what it's not not kind of very
intimidating I mean how do you as
creators sort of narrow down your vision
without you know just throwing
everything in the wall and seeing what
sticks how do you keep focused when it
comes to the final game I don't know
we're just we've always been really
fortunate in that regard we just talked
about things we want to do
we kind of start narrowing in it's it's
kind of a gut thing you start tossing
around ideas and you and the ones that
you really want to pursue kind of come
to the top you know we had a couple
things going into it that we knew we
wanted the space Western kind of thing
so that kind of limited where we were
going to go and then I always want you
know very pulpy physics and like I was
talking about the chunky machinery so
visually we knew we wanted to do that
tim was very much into talking about
like I'm having branding on everything
and he loved coming up with the slogans
and kind of some of the silliness of
that and then I started you know getting
in there with like oh we should have
like corporate company towns and so I
kind of just snowballed from there
it's just it's a very organic process
with us obsidian RPGs I think when I
think about them at least I think of
like a story structure that can really
branch off depending on decisions you
make isn't gonna be the case here or are
there like more branches I don't know
how is that like how was the game
structured as opposed to your previous
games um pretty much the same you know
there's a main storyline you can divert
pretty significantly from it in terms of
its it's the same story from beginning
to end but it's your story about how it
plays out on the scientist rescues
rescues you early on you're part of a
doomed colony ship that got lost on the
way it is to the colony and so there's
still hundreds of thousands of colonists
waiting to be revived that have been
just sitting left out there so the
scientists rescue used rescues you and
he wants you to help him save the rest
of the colonists and take on the
corporate board but you could very
quickly turn on him and decide no I'm
gonna side with the board instead so
yeah once again it always comes back to
player choice and letting the player
play the character that they want to
play and make the choices that they want
to make when it comes to so I was
watching some of the gameplay I think
I'm hopefully gonna sneak in and see the
behind closed doors Emma tomorrow but
one of the cool things that you're doing
is fear sort of embracing that and not
just about you know being special and
having perks but it's kind of how the
game you know puts you up against these
obstacles and you can choose to sort of
embrace that and get a fear of it oh oh
sorry
like that will have a detriment to you
and I have affected but you also get a
perk point
you talked a little bit about how that
was developed and implemented into the
game yeah that was something that Tim
wanted to really pursue early on the you
know the concept of the flawed hero and
a lot of RPGs and games in general by
the end of the game you're super human
nothing can stop you so this is really
kind of an aid for people who really
want to dig down into the role-playing
aspect of it you know you've been
damaged a lot by robots so wrapped it on
so you can get a phobia of those things
you can become addicted to drugs and
it's kind of like that's it's it's
totally optional but players who really
want to get deep into the role-playing
can give themselves those limitations
and then challenge themselves to
overcome them and see how that changes
the feel of the game can you ever work
your way into a corner by getting too
many close we hope not yeah you should
you should be able to finish the game no
matter how many flaws you take you can
only let me rephrase that you can only
take three flaws in normal mode
I believe you can take five in supernova
it's funny I think I talk about a lot
how I think the phrase role-playing game
for about like 15 years now in games is
often misused sometimes by me like you
have these role-playing these this
progression system in a shooter and
people say oh it's got role-playing
elements but it seems like recently
there's been this resurgence of games
that are like no this is this is what
role-playing games are this what it
means to roleplay do you see outer
worlds fitting into that new I don't
know if it like Renaissance might be a
strong word but you see the outer worlds
kind of pushing that envelope as well I
hope so I mean this is pretty much the
same kind of game we always like to make
so it seems weird that it seems much
more mainstream now because we always
felt like we were kind of on the
periphery and very much niche you know
and the people who loved who liked our
games really loved our games but the
general you know the general gaming
population didn't really have as much
awareness and it just seems like that's
people have come around to what we've
always known is the appeal of making
choices and being able to have the game
react to those choices is the more
widespread appeal changed at all how you
approach these games is there an effort
or a desire to make them more accessible
considering the fact that maybe millions
more people are gonna be interested in
this kind of game
I don't think so what we've always
wanted to do and as any game maker wants
to do is make their games feel better
more polished and by accessible I want
more people to be able to get into the
game so yeah we want to find ways to
kind of not drive people away with walls
of numbers but at the same time we we're
very aware of our of our hardcore
fanbase who really wants to delve deep
into those things so we don't want to
abandon you know our fans who really
want us to explore those things at the
expense of I mean we don't want to you
know abandon them to get a bigger a
bigger audience
but the positive of what you're talking
about is the fact that I don't think we
need to do as much of that now because
it seems like the rest of it the rest of
the industry is turning a little bit
towards what we do so they're doing a
good job for us I guess how do you how
do you I mean you kind of touch it there
a little bit but when you are looking to
create a game like this I mean how it
depths do you go to appease those fans
whereas you know keeping it balanced for
new players as well as you know over the
years I'm sure you'll have had you're
very vocal fans telling you what they do
and don't like why your games how do you
take on board what old fans are saying
and you know reiterating to you and
keeping it fresh for new we really just
like when we're brainstorming the ideas
for the game we really kind of just
follow our guts and that we kind of know
at least we believe we know what people
who are really into this kind of game
want and that's really what we want to
deliver and for us it always felt like
we just need to you know sand down some
of the rough edges and you know make it
a little bit the presentation a little
bit better you know we've always I mean
our goal has always been if you go back
and read you know some of the interviews
I've done in the past or tim has done in
the past we talked about making our
combat more accessible or more fun
because one of the things you here have
heard in the past about RPGs it's like
well the story is really great but the
combats a little bit lacking so every
time we're like we're always trying to
make the combat more engaging is better
so it's just a progression I don't think
we've diverted from our path all that
much like I said I think it's kind of
like weird
lining up with what more people want
these days than us kind of like changing
what we're doing
you mentioned much of like making the
combat more appealing and it's funny so
much of modern RPG combat is finding
creative ways to obfuscate numbers
that's I don't know if that's accurate
maybe it is can you talk about that what
it's like to kind of yeah like we we
want these hardcore people to know these
numbers are behind the scenes these
intricate systems are still unfolding
behind the scenes even though we're kind
of putting a sheen on it so to speak
what's that like well that's probably
the hardest thing to do because in an
RPG and especially when you're doing an
isometric game it's a lot easier
turn-based because then it's much more
about the character you're building in
terms of what their skill is you know
because you say I'm going to take this
shot and then they you know the dice are
rolled figuratively and you either make
it or not based on your character's
skill not the fearsome person playing
the game and that's what it gets tricky
and first-person because if you if you
go too far that direction in the
first-person game it feels wrong it
doesn't feel like the game is doing that
it just feels like it's not responsive
so that's probably the trickiest part
and I think my favorite part of that is
I don't have to deal with that because I
do the story in the end they art and I
just get to like critique them and say
oh no no it doesn't feel good make it
feel better
that's kind of I tell them out all the
time make it good and they've been doing
that so that's good what do you think um
you know you Tim worked together many
years ago but working together a long
time what is it about your partnership
that you know comes into each game what
do you think really makes it a Tim and
Leonard game I think it's a it's a
combination of the the dark and the
silly and it's also we're really
fortunate that early on we just started
we were kind of throwing together it
wasn't even our choice but I'm I'm very
much on the art side or at least I
started on the art side and he was very
much on the programming and design side
so he was he's colorblind he knew very
early on he didn't really know much
about art so he kind of let me handle
that and I'm like oh you you know way
more about system stuff than I do so
it's been very good because we're we're
really strong in areas that the other
one isn't as weaker in and then of
course we build the worlds together
you know when there's a lot of
compromise but it really it it's it's
really interesting because if I did a
game it would probably would skew a
little bit too dark and if he did a game
at least in my opinion would skew a
little too silly so I just think it's a
really nice mix of our personalities and
our and our preferences and games you
talk about like your hallmarks kind of
your trademarks yours narrative Lee and
artistically the combination of dark and
silly but for you personally how was
your writing evolved since the days of
safe fallout that's a really good
question I always dabbled in writing
when I was younger but I wasn't really I
never really considered myself a writer
I went to school for art I was an art
director on the original fallout it was
only when we were playing the original
fallout we didn't kind of we didn't
really like a lot of what was being done
in the writing it wasn't a group of us
had gotten together and kind of like
said this is what the vision for the
game is so then we kind of went off and
did all of our art and then came back
and we're really looking at it and like
this isn't what we had originally
conceived of so me and Jason Anderson
the other the third guy who was in Troy
go with me and Tim started rewriting a
lot of the dialogue in the game that's
kind of when I rediscovered my passion
for writing I think I think I just think
about over the years I just think more
about the process and more about what
I'm trying to accomplish back then and
even still an Arcanum it was kind of
just free willing just whatever came to
mind whatever I'm going to do not really
kind of like stepping back and looking
at it and it I've been doing much more
directing and editing and you know
helping other writers kind of like get
what we want for the game as opposed to
doing a lot of the writing myself which
was you know and fall out in Arcanum I
was doing a lion's share of that stuff
well I'm afraid we're out of time thank
you so much for joining us when can
people play the artworks I'm sorry when
can people be playing yeah so October
25th it's not that long to wait thank
you and if you're joining us at home
make sure you don't go anywhere we'll be
right back with Marvel Ultimate Alliance
3
you